[Musique]
quel beau générique mesdames et
messieurs bonjour ça y est c'est fait
c'était la dernière fois que je vous le
disais journal un peu particulier vous
le savez mon 7000e déjeuner avec vous je
ne sais rien de ce qui va se passer
jusqu'à 14h15
là
[Musique]
jo
chante
puis on vient de l'apprendre le décès de
la chanteuse israélienne rika zaraï elle
cette atteinte
elle s'est éteinte à l'âge de 82 ans
c'est l'ambassade d'israël en france qui
nous l'annoncent profondément attristés
de la disparition de rika zaraï c'est la
journée du pull moche de noël émission
spéciale tous nos candidats sont venus
avec leur plus beau pull ou les plus
moches on sait pas mais en tout cas
voilà on avait tous envie comme ce soir
c'est le début des vacances scolaires
ah bah voilà d'être en tenue de noël
donc moi j'ai rudolf g rudolf et
lorraine regardez c'était la quatrième
édition de ces championnats du monde du
pull moche organisé à albi dans le tarn
cette année avec la crise sanitaire le
concours a eu lieu 100% en ligne
les participants n'ont pas eu à se
déplacer jusqu'à albi et c'est un
certain fabien chaman taux qui a été
plébiscité par les internautes pour la
catégorie solo avec un pull europe père
noël de très bon goût et des barresi
emprunté à sa femme mais soir à toutes
et à tous je m'appelle avant tout petit
j'ai 23 ans et je suis étudiante en
master 2 management des établissements
et structures gérontologique à l'iae de
caen afin de devenir directrice
d'établissement de santé au quotidien je
suis une personne simple sociable
dynamique et toujours souriante
sylvie tellier qui va se faire à manger
à d'irrigation avec l'homme invisible
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
miss france 2000 21e est et restera miss
normandie
première dauphine est miss provence
cette année encore comme en mer
bravo à vis l'amendé et bravo à toutes
les suites judiciaires après l'élection
de miss france 2000 21 samedi soir le
parquet de paris annonce ce matin avoir
ouvert une enquête pour injure à
caractère raciste et provocation à la
haine raciale
sont visés les messages antisémites
diffusés sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'encontre d'april benayoun miss
provence élue première dauphine qui se
mord aux dents à gauche parce qu'elles
ont beaucoup d'arabes adjoindra si c'est
très bien je suis allé c'est incroyable
rien oui ça aussi à l'humour jouissance
on est d'accord elle à 0 vague je ne
pense pas à ça va on va revenir aux
fondamentaux
côté cultes comme on va au 8 rue ardeur
et mal aussi avec le h donc acté y'avait
raider oui senna sur de logiques oui
absolument nycthémère n y c'est et h&m
aux accents graves erreurs nycthémère
mais c'est vrai que c'est fait c'est
elle et bien prononcé
il vaut mieux jean-pierre on est devenu
des
du bout de la rue
du bout de la région est ce que vous
avez fait le plein du traîneau pour les
cadeaux mais évidemment le traîneau est
garée devant le studio et les plats
craquer génial est-ce que vous avez
autre aspect station pour vous déplacer
oui j'ai mon attestation c'est pas
évident à dire père noël bonjour merci
d'être avec nous d'abord comment allez
vous en cette période particulière
pourrait vous distribuez comme
d'habitude les cadeaux aux enfants
oui tout va bien tout est prêt pour
distribuer des cadeaux aux enfants on a
toutes les dérogations pour que je
puisse m'en voler dans le ciel
faire le tour du monde pour porter tous
les cadeaux aux enfants cette année le
père noël reste dans sa bulle
même si l' oms a certifié qu'il était
immunisé contre le coc vide
ils donnent le bon exemple comme ici en
thaïlande
réservation obligatoire alors pendant
quelques minutes
cette petite fille là rien que pour elle
comme il les adore tous aussi bien les
les rollers que les petites babioles à
trois francs six sous
il adore les chausseurs tacler les
chaussettes ils ont eu des slips même
les slips c'est fantastique c'est quoi
cette photo jean-pierre c'est à salles
sur mer en caleçon nous réveillant le
matin sortir d'autres photos comme
sentiment pour cette première manche
vous avez 5 militer dans mes folies
ce clin d'oeil posté sur twitter par la
police nationale du pas de calais le
père noël en cellule vous le voyez
accompagné de ce commentaire
humoristique
nous procédons actuellement à une
vérification d'identité d'un individu
nous ayons été signalé comme pénétrant
dans les habitations par les toits alors
rassurez vous rassurez vous le père noël
était en règle et il a été libéré four
va regarder passerelle sicre à préparer
le repas de noël et bien j'étais sûr que
l'esprit de noël à les faire fondre son
petit coeur de guimauve
[Musique]
tout le coeur de guy monde non mais
c'est pas possible faire exploser leurs
tableaux elle vous n'avez pas envie
d'arriver personnes quelle réaction ce
soir aux annonce à l'instant d'olivier
verrons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui c'est une le couvre feu pourrait
être avancée de deux heures dès le 2
janvier c'est une mesure réclamée par le
maire de nice christian estrosi claire
chapal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
des milliers de personnes coller au
coeur aux ânes pour fêter le nouvel an
presque obligatoire mais aucune
distanciation officiellement ici le coc
vide a disparu
j'espère qu'en 2021 je pourrais être
super riches est mince et que ma famille
et mes amis restera en bonne santé
bonjour monsieur qu'est ce que vous avez
fait hier soir
revivons mais à 3 personnes vous êtes
vous étiez vous dans les règles j'écoute
bfm tv alors comme il me
il me comble toute la journée c'est pas
sympa c'est pas sympa ségo croquant
vraiment souhaité ce sera dur de faire
que tu veux
qu'est ce que tu as deux audi dont
[Applaudissements]
j'arrête le coeur serré
je suis confiant pour la suite sophie
adore les régions je laisse les clés ont
volontiers est une maison qui est en
très bon état et sophie merci à tous ce
dernier au revoir je vous souhaite un
joyeux noël malgré les difficultés
vivement la prochaine année je vous
embrasse du fond du coeur merci je vous
aime je vous oublierai jamais